right now visit creditkarma.com
win to open your free account and start
winning instant karma
again go to credit karma win money to
sign up for a free
and start winning instant karma let's
start the show
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to
your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
all right anyways guys we're here
riffing with griffin the new and
improved
i know it looks exactly the same but i
guarantee you today's episode is going
to be uh
a little different a little special
because
i got my my own personal jamie i got a
jamie i got a george i got somebody here
sitting behind the desk at the riffle
griffith studios it's going to help me
out
and you guys are going to meet him
shortly but once again i just want to
thank everybody for being here
make sure you catch me gaming daily on
twitch eric griffin gaming
and thank you for subscribing sharing
doing all the things commenting
trolling everything that you do i
appreciate you and once again welcome to
whoa okay all right the woo-woos are
done
uh oh what happened oh that's my phone
um anyways you know thanks for being
here guys and like i said
okay so what do i always say i'm a
one-man show so i had somebody help me i
reached out to a few people that reached
out to me on the internet they were like
yo man i want to help you then a couple
things happen
this person that person but this
particular person said all right i'm
gonna help you and i said well let's try
it out so we cut together some videos
from me that i have on my patreon so
make sure you check that out
uh patreon.com eric griffin for
that content so there's a couple of
videos up there already of like you know
iphone and with griffin made by my man
so let's meet him now ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the podcast welcome
to the
we're from griffith studios uh nate but
we're gonna call him wiggy
here he is wiggy what up guys are you on
the screen
yeah i'm here i'm up in the right hand
corner he's oh okay so he's over there
guys right you're over there now i'm
right next to you oh hey
the magic that we're doing here at river
griffin studios
so uh nate's here guys and what do you
what do you like to be called nate wiggy
uh whatever is fine either way
uh everybody calls me wiggy but why did
that how did that start uh well my
name's nate wigman
i know but like who uh who was the first
person to be like we can just call you
wiggy
because my last name is griffin so
people call me griff yeah it had to be
at the skate park i don't know when i
was maybe even before that maybe when i
was like 10 or something i don't know it
was really young
and then it just stuck and everybody
wiggy wiggy smalls or
oh whatever got it got it got it because
you're into it you're one of those white
boys it was in the rap is that what
it was a little bit into rock more when
i was that age probably yeah
you were into rock more yeah but now but
you and you're from seattle yeah
so he's from seattle and he's here um
and you're like directing and doing all
kinds of stuff like that right yeah
kind of kind of trying my best yeah see
i don't even know this guy could be like
a [ __ ]
i've done some stuff yeah i mean he
could be a serial killer for all i know
you know what i mean he's
just you know always has his shirt off
just everything on his instagram shirt
off at all times
skating you know doing like you're just
like and then you have like so many
followers and people
watching your stuff i don't even know do
you know why
is it just because you do you think it's
strictly because you're talented or is
it because you're cute like what is it
uh show me your ways because i have no
idea it doesn't work for me
i gotta i mean i got a bunch of
followers because i
was uh like a personal photographer and
videographer of uh little peep
who oh uh and i shot like a ton of his
music videos so that's
how i like and he was giving you shout
outs he was giving me shout outs he was
like
look at this he's the cute videographer
or whatever so all the girls
oh yeah you piece of [ __ ]
god i hate you um and that's like i got
to keep rachel
away from him you know what i mean like
she might be like oh that's what i
should be going for
no you're safe man so so when you
okay so this is a funny thing to happen
so i'm showing him how to work my
equipment and just
you know and i'm saying so we have this
way to like he's going to be able to
look up stuff on the internet and i show
it like oh
put on the screen so it's a joke i go oh
let's look up like i say oh
so like you know you'll be able to look
this up wiggy and it's like fat white
girls so i put fat white girls in the
search engine
right and porn came up
i don't know if that's insulting or
is it uplifting like you know what i
mean
yeah it was really weird i was not i
wasn't expecting that either and then
you go to images
and it's all just uh like who just like
just regular regular normal fat white
girls just normal fat white girls but
you and and first i wanted to make sure
it wasn't like my cert you know how like
you know how like instagram shows you
what you've been looking at most of the
time so that's why it just shows up so i
said well let me make sure i'm not this
is not my fault
so he looked at it on his phone too and
it says fat white girl and then porn
comes up
i mean i is that what is that is that
sentence enough for it to be
immediately porn there must just be so
much like
really fantasization of it i don't know
people must just love their fat white
girls they gotta love fat white girls to
be like that right i just i
it just doesn't make any sense to me
that it would just
default to porn like i wonder what else
defaults to porn like that if you said
fat white girls uh
what if you put like fat asian girls
does is it still porn
you know what i mean or is it sumo
wrestlers come up or something like that
uh asian adolescents have a higher
c trunk it's like real stories are there
fat asians yes i'm one of them
this is what i'm saying so that's like
normal stuff like if you were looking up
like you could just look up fat
asian girls and real real stories come
up with like stuff but you put fat
white girls and immediately it's porn
yeah
i don't know that's steve that seems uh
that is interesting seems very strange
to me
so this is gonna be an all wiggy episode
in terms of like he is like
leading the way so i said let's come up
with some topics let's see how we can do
this
and let's see if this format works for
riffing with griffin so we'll know in
the comments if they're like nah get rid
of this dude
right bring him back you know like oh
this is great great
whatever you guys are saying right now
it's probably right underneath the
comments right now but
i know you had a list of things that we
can we can go into for this episode and
see
this i feel more chill now cause i feel
like yes i got somebody behind the
the captain's chair oh yeah helping me
helping me do this [ __ ]
so let's uh make some money so i could
pay him
the riffin cinematic universe they're oh
i like that the
the gm the gmu yeah yeah
no gcu gcu yeah the gcu ooh that sounds
like
like a rapper gcu what's up y'all i'm
gcu
thought you knew boo boo so what you got
what what's going on what did you want
to like go into i don't know uh
you're you're so into uh all the
superhero [ __ ] i thought you could uh
explain some of that to me
um because you don't get it are you not
into super no no i'm super i'm into it
but
i feel like i don't know if it's a
generational thing like if
my generation maybe missed i know
there's definitely kids my age that are
into it and
younger but uh like i was super into
like obviously like like
the dark knight and like okay let me ask
you this
spider-man well let me ask you this is
your generation do you think comic books
have passed your generation
like because that's what it really is
about yeah probably i
probably i'd say i have a couple comic
books but mostly just because they look
wow cool i have a bunch of comic books
man i should actually i appreciate them
maybe i should bring my comic books out
and be like look at all these comic
books that i have that would explain it
you know i think i have a do i have them
right here let me see if i have them
right here we can always edit
okay yeah
you know we could just do like a video
fast
just do a speed you know i went to go
yeah i want to go look for the comic
books and they're gone i don't know
where you know what it is i haven't
unpacked i've
lived here for like i don't know how
long with this new place and i still got
boxes in the in the closets and i act
like i'm like you know i've unpacked but
anyways getting back to it though is
like so you have a little bit of comics
but that wasn't your thing because for
my generation it was all about comics
like we had comic books and it was like
you got them weekly and
we never would have dreamed that like
spider-man would be on the big screen
like in my generation was like
you will never see this in movies so you
have to look at comic books and cartoons
and now we live in this world where you
don't need comic books because you can
see it on the big screen
so that's why but i feel like
everybody's into it equally you're not
into comic books
superhero i'm just saying a superhero
genre no but i just mean like all the
new
i feel like there's so many i mean
you're always talking about like
all these different shows that are on on
disney or
right right like marvel shows like i
just yeah like it look like the marvel
uh cinematic
universe i kind of just get lost i feel
like like there seems like there's so
much
well because there's so much because
it's based off the comics right and the
the marvel comics have so many
um what do you call it there's so many
you know characters in the marvel
universe
and they tried to get a bunch of them in
with the avengers and and then uh
there's x-men
and but then like you know they they
broke off because marvel sold the rights
to
you know sony it's not something so now
the universes are like a part but now
they're back together
for their first time so like because
like in the in the sony universe no no
i'm sorry in the marvel universe
they were not allowed to say the word
mutant
because it because of what because it
was owned by
it was like that was copyright for x-men
that's the sony universe yes
okay so now that now they're combined
you know you're gonna hear
you're gonna hear that but like it's
speaking of that you say that
you know they have the the newfangled um
jupiter's legacy that's what it's called
jupiter's legacy so
um on amazon they had that show called
the boys which is like a rated r
superhero show did you see that i saw a
preview for it
a preview for it i don't even know who
you are
who are you well this is what i wanted
you to explain it you're busy
i'm gonna get into it no it's not i like
the super boys looks cool for sure now
the thing that's good about the boys is
because it's rated r
it's like really grimy gritty nudity sex
violence gore yeah you know that's
what's good about that
netflix just recently released this show
called
jupiter's legacy and it's like i believe
it's their version of the boys but on
netflix right so trying to compete
because it was a huge hit i mean the
boys was like a huge hit for amazon
i'm watching this jupiter show and i
gotta tell you i'm a little bored
i'm a little bored there's not enough
superhero [ __ ] okay
like the superhero stuff is a backdrop
you know they got the flying the powers
the eyes it's like a lot of origin story
going on
and a lot of like family drama and not
enough
kicking ass and you know shooting lasers
out of your eyes
i don't like the balance right now right
now it's like 70 30 and i need to [ __ ]
like
60 40 55 you know
55 45 and then i'd be happier but i
don't know i'm not gonna not
watch it i'm gonna continue with the
season i'm on like four or five episodes
and i'm still a little bit like okay
what the hell is going on let's get to
it but you know
but to get back to what you're saying i
don't know
i just i really think it goes back to
what i was saying about the comic book
universe and knowing all these
characters
right i mean i liked cloak and dagger i
liked alpha flight i liked
avengers x-men uh marvel team team-up
but
spider-man would like team up with like
all sorts of marvel characters and then
todd mcfarlane he took over spider-man
cartoon he was drawing he's like this
fantastic artist and then
he led into like his own comic book uh
company
and then he made spawn and so you know i
have like the first 12 spawn i don't
even know if they're worth anything
uh you know so you know it's just that
was the what you did
back then you collected comics and then
you know you you
learned about the lore and you like you
you know you followed these characters
and so now they're being they're being
brought to life with cgi
and technology so it's kind of replacing
comic books with
that if that makes sense did i explain
it yeah that makes sense for sure
yeah i don't believe it i have a your
tone
your tone of voice right now is that you
don't believe
no i'm just super monotone are you are
you saying yeah we're gonna have to fix
that
no but um i have a giant my dad actually
got me
a j just like a giant marvel book okay
that has like the history of
i don't know everything marvel i'll
bring it over it's pretty sick yeah oh
yeah cause you probably don't even
appreciate it
no i i did but when i was young i used
to draw like
because my dad's a artist so he would he
would try and get me to draw
superheroes i i think i have a i have a
bunch of old superhero drawings of your
drawings yeah
and that's where you would like edit
this and show it right there yeah here's
my
my other drawing he's gonna be all about
him all of a sudden like what the [ __ ]
happened to my pocket
yeah i didn't mean to come over welcome
to the wiggy show
okay what else so yeah what else you got
hero mode
tell me about that oh look at you this
is like this
this is great i love this hero mode is
this movie that i did with bobby lee
uh produced by his wife's his cousin's
husband ej okay so it's
the movie was caught something else
before but it's just this movie about
this kid
this this uh kid who you know his mom
own his mom and father owned a video
game company
and he is a genius kid he knows how to
program and all this kind of stuff
enough
his dad dies and but not in the movie
but you just know his dad's gone his dad
had died and then so now
this company is kind of flandering and
it's going through some issues with this
new
new video game they're gonna try to
launch and the mom recruits the son to
come to the company and really help
because he knows how to fix everything
it's it's a kid
it's like a kid movie you know what i
mean it's a family-friendly movie
uh you know sean austin green not sean
austin greece
sean austin you know the hobbit guy did
i'm saying his name right
yes bobby uh
i don't even know remember all the
people in the movie um you know
we're gonna have to pause
[Laughter]
because i have to move my car and we're
back yes
so i had to move my car for rachel i
hate tandem parking man
you know you live with people and you
have like the one spot i live
i live in a house but oh excuse me
but it's uh it's not as nice as this
place but uh
it's we have like one parking spot in
the back and then one in the front and
they're both kind of like ridiculous
it's just i just i
i just when i when i buy a house if i
buy a house
hopefully this show get picked up and
i'm gonna buy a house gotta have that
nice
you know i need to have like where i
don't have to move my car for anybody
i'm sick of it
exactly so annoying and then like the
thing too is like the parking garage in
this place
there's no reception so like
if you have an issue you have to
it's like it gets annoying like if i
need rachel to move her car and i forgot
you know i got to be i can't text her
and be like can you come move your car i
got to actually get out of the car
come up to the area text and if she's
not answering you still got to go back
up and be like yo
so then like we i had this funny video
of her from like my front door camera
of her yelling at me because i didn't
uh and then my mom just called me you
know i don't know if you know this but
my mom
my mom has dementia it's like mild
dementia but it's still dementia
and she's now she's calling me every day
and it's just
bananas because she doesn't know where
she is and she thinks she's someplace
that she's not
and she knows she wants to be someplace
else so she's like telling me like eric
i'm
you know i need you to call me a cab
because i need to go home
you know and it's like you home you know
and then she'll be like
yesterday she said i want um
i think i should get a bike so i can
ride my bike
and i'm like you you can't ride a bike
you you i'm 80 years old you're riding a
bike
you know what i mean so it's just you
know but at least
she's calling me which is like good
because she's like reaching out to me
for like whatever comfort or whatever it
is in her mind she's like oh i gotta
call eric
so that's good but at the same time it's
like i'm reminded now every single day
of this like horrific thing you know
what i mean yeah
that's tough for sure it is tough i
don't know people out there that are
dealing with
dementia it's uh it's a tough thing it's
just because it's tough not about
it's not even what it's doing to her
because now i but i am seeing that she's
confused so something's happening with
her
but it's also really hard on the loved
ones because we have to
relive every single day that our parent
is not the same or grandparent is not
the same as they were right
so you know but anyways
back to comic books um you know
are you even into sci-fi fantasy all
that kind of stuff
um a little bit i could i could not just
say no
don't don't don't try to like make me
feel good
just say no i'm not into that [ __ ]
you're already like no but i
like i can get into like anything i'm
i'm pretty easy
so here we go i swear i like star wars
i love i like star wars you like star
wars what does that mean you like star
wars i mean i
watched star wars when i was like
younger got super into it
you got super into it yeah i had a i had
a star wars phase for sure
[Laughter]
it was a phase i still i still like star
wars i watch the new ones when they come
out you know
even though they're trash it's a oh yeah
garbanzo beans at least the mandalorian
is good i like the mandalorian
see need to watch that what because you
do you even have disney plus or it does
oh yeah like skater plus it's
all skater channel yeah what would you
do like you're on tick tock looking at
skate videos
is that something is that what you're
doing where do you get your
okay what's your number one source of
entertainment where do you go first
podcast honestly i listen to everybody's
podcast oh
okay so you're right it's like podcast
24 7. so you go okay so you can do
podcasts
airpods podcasts all right like so you
don't see you're not a
instagram tick tock i recently
like i i haven't been on tick tock as
much as uh i used to i used to just get
stuck in tick tock yeah you can't but
reals is like that too now
yeah you go to reels and you're just
like yeah it's the same [ __ ] yeah and
then and then yeah since
instagram is so tailored to me it's just
all skate videos
now and then it's either girls or skate
videos so it's just like
right yeah oh that's interesting because
i
i always say this too is like i can't
believe how many like i'm looking at my
thing now when you go to like the
the browser area you search oh yeah it's
just
bad chicks yeah it's all girls like it's
just
unbelievable and then occasionally it'll
be something like oh here's a jake paul
video because i was looking
at like the fight stuff yo okay what do
you think about that what do you think
about uh
gotcha hat about who you see the
you saw him take floyd's hat right oh
whatever man
like these guys are just it's like the
wwf
you're right no 100 percent it's a w
because you could really get hurt in the
wwe or f or whatever it's called now
you can really get hurt because they're
actually big bodies you know and these
guys are doing the same thing they're
actually going to be punching each other
so it's like you know a tough thing now
i get it they're showmen
and the rest of the boxing and fighting
world needs to get on their page
dude like these boxers need to get
social media managers
they need to be online doing fight
videos they need to be making content so
people could so they can get a following
so then people will be like yeah i want
to watch that guy fight like the
the the the you know what's funny is
what happens
what's happening in comedy is the same
thing that is happening now
in boxing where it's not necessarily the
traditional
pure like in comedy it's not just the
traditional pure comedians who are
making it as comedians
now these look kind of like you know
podcast people
uh youtube stars vine stars
reels tik tok they're coming in making
funny videos and they're
they're funneling that into public
appearance and becoming comedians
because they want people to come watch
them live that same [ __ ] is happening
now in boxing
where it's becoming about personalities
over
you know just traditional old-school
skills look
love them or hate them they're bringing
attention to
um combat fighting yeah definitely he
definitely
knows how to uh get paid for a fight
logan and his brother yeah because this
is one one's logan
but i guarantee you this i'm gonna i'm
predicting something for you right now
okay
you heard it here first on riffing with
griffin
i guarantee you that
there's going to be a beef between the
brothers
that jake paul and logan paul are going
to have some kind of fight
they've had it in the past on their you
with their youtube [ __ ] but
this is going to be a bigger fight no
it's gonna be like that really it's
gonna be like a real
like serious like and it's gonna be like
news and they're gonna be they're gonna
be leaking things
and it's gonna be serious and they're
gonna be like you know they're gonna and
they're gonna fight
and they're gonna set up a fight yeah
and it's all gonna be fake
yeah i think that's inevitable for sure
yeah the fight will be real right
but the build up and the setup and
everybody taking sides and then you know
they'll sell a million pay-per-views and
boom
you know i just you know i don't know
yeah they know how to sell a fight they
know how to teleport that's for sure
that's what i think about it yeah yeah i
think i thought it was pretty funny that
he
took his hat and ran off but i mean like
like for real
yeah like come on you know i mean i
don't
i mean logan paul is a big dude though
definitely i mean i you know
he could if he catches floyd with one
who knows
uh yeah are you ready i don't know if
you're into fighting are you really into
fighting not do not really know but i i
listen i mean
throughout awards he's not fighting he's
bringing he's the one bringing the [ __ ]
but i
i listen to all people well i listen to
all the podcasts and
you can't escape it so you're getting
all your information from podcast
so you you don't have you don't have
your own thoughts your own opinions
you're just like okay well this one
podcast makes me feel this way no i just
i hear about it i
so i i catch things here and there ufc
god
you just catch things here and there
yeah
monster brennan shop brandon joe rogan
that's where you're getting all your
information from brendan and joe rogan
okay well that tells you right a grain
of salt with a grain of salt just tells
you right here everybody what you need
to know about this kid
okay unbelievable i have my own opinions
okay well i'd like to hear one of them
about something
all right what else you got what else uh
we did hero mode we did uh did we finish
hero mode this is here mode i don't even
know when it's coming i think it's
coming out in the theaters or off video
on demand or something it's gonna be one
of those
but you should find that it's funny if
you want to see me and bobby lee we have
a scene together
so that's gonna be fun yeah i can't wait
to see that yeah yeah so that'll be good
oh yeah indiana that's another good the
other chick that's in it just
this beautiful australian young
australian actress
and she's like in the in the not disney
world but it's kind of like that
similar but youtube like just some like
teen youtube show that she's like
huge on it she's actually a great singer
too she's got her own music
her last name is i don't i never get her
last name right it's miss sarah
masara yeah indiana missouri yeah
indiana masara
yeah so she's got she's got two million
instagram followers jesus you know um
but she's great
i've listened to her music i told her
i'd say this is great stuff good stuff
so uh anyways sorry but hiromo we did it
oh yeah
yeah i'm excited for that um
are you excited i don't know if you're
really excited yes dude that's gonna be
sick you and bobby lee
hell yeah i don't know if if that's your
level of excitement
like i don't know if this this is where
you're at like that's the levels
i i started watching um guest house
uh-huh
turned it off and then found out you
were in it so i watched the rest of it
so like so disingenuous do you hear we
said it
but it's not no i dude and you were
hella funny in that you're so
you the [ __ ] cop okay maybe i believe
him
dude you were that actually i was dying
honestly but i'm giving you one demerit
that you're you're on the board for
demerit for this episode
already yeah that's one demerit all
right all right what about the comedy
store
the comedy store is back so i went for
the first time
was it last night i think it was or a
couple nights ago this weekend
this particular past weekend because
this is out on monday so
yeah the past weekend it was great to be
back at the place i hadn't been in a
year it is extremely different
you know especially the way they have it
set up in the or it's just so weird it's
like it really feels like an empty room
with a couple of chairs in it you know
and so it just feels like a 12 45
a.m spot like back in the day you know
you're still doing your time you know
you're doing your spot all the big heavy
hitters are gone and then like they're
still doing a show and there's like
you know 13 people in the crowd and you
you're still doing your set because you
love being at the store
that's what it feels like every spot but
the people want to be there i can tell
they just like
you know everybody's got great energy
and it's just
good just good to be back and i just
don't know how long
before you know the restrictions let up
and then the next thing you know the
place is full again and people have
their masks off or whatever whatever i
don't know how far away we are from that
seems like we're like five or six months
away
but i've done like this week this past
week i did a lot of shows
i did a show at this place called
supernova it's like this outdoor venue
in um in hollywood and a lot of comics
are doing that show so that's a great
show
and then we got uh the comedy store and
i'm gonna be doing a lot i did the laugh
factory so
i'm right back in the swing of doing
shows and there's this other one called
the jam in the van
a lot of people are doing that one so
that's right down the street from me
which is great
so you know comedy's back in la so i
don't know what people are talking about
that comedy's dead in la it
is not it's coming back it's back it's
strong and it's only going to get better
so all those people that left bye
bye yeah i'm excited to get
go big uh get back in the comedy store i
got my wand down so i could just cast
spells on wiggy
where'd you where did you get all these
tattoos man what's up with all the
tattoos are you addicted to tattoos um
and this is where you picture yourself
up right now
you were addicted to getting tattoos uh
no i was just all my
i i don't know i had a kind of a dark
period in my life
oh here we go and i don't know i got a
bunch of tattoos
this is wrong i like the cabinet
yeah man when you're moving the car
[Laughter]
see i believe you so but wait
does your tattoos have a story or is it
just all dumb
dumb young dumb [ __ ] is that are there
is there anyone that you're like this
one means this one's my
my uncle who helped me when he was like
do you have stories too there's some
stories yeah
what's the best story uh what tattoo has
the best story that means the most which
one means the most to you
um i don't know the this one was my
first one he's like my taint this one
how did you know what how do you know
you didn't see that uh
on your arm yeah i got this one that was
my first one oh
that means a lot it's the well what does
it mean it's the scooby-doo
uh the of course the captain cutler
the dudes this guy came in my dms
because i called
this guy i did some interview and called
this guy the swamp monster and then some
guy
dm me like paragraphs saying like
it's not the swamp monster that's
captain cutler
how do you say you're a scooby-doo fan
and you don't even know i was like bro
chill out wow so the scooby-doo mob who
came after you
i guess uh i didn't know there was a
scooby-doo mop he was really mad i was
like
and i and i replied and i was like dude
that's captain dn
and he totally it just went over his
head is there a scooby-doo fan club can
we look that up is there excuses i
finally got somebody to look [ __ ] up for
me is there a scooby-doo fan club
who's in charge who's in charge of the
scooby-doo fan club
scooby-doo fan club everybody that's
what we're going to find out i guess
there's got to be right there's a fan
club for everything on facebook scooby
doo addicts.com
wow what a word to use addicts
you're a scooby-doo addict wow they're
posting
pretty frequently you know what's the
craziest tattoo i've ever seen
on someone because it's because because
like because it reminds me of an
addiction type of thing is this
it was this waitress at the laugh
factory in long beach
she was a um
what is what is that will ferrell news
anchor character
ron bergen ron burgundy she was a ron
burgundy fan like not a will ferrell fan
you hear what i'm saying she was a ron
burgundy fan
so she loved that podcast son and then
she had
it was like on her thigh i believe it
was her thigh
a full picture of ron burgundy
that's pretty funny so that's the kind
of like weirdness
so you have scooby-doo on your so what's
the dumbest one you have
what's the one where you go uh oh okay i
shouldn't have got this my
my i mean i don't really regret any of
them but
um maybe a couple but
uh this one says slap it's just like
some really dumb [ __ ]
it says what s-l-a-t-t slat it's like
some
some like rap [ __ ] like something like
thug
some made-up word yeah it's like some
young thug but my friend was like
uh dude that would be so stupid if you
got that and i was like and i was like
if you pay for it i'll get it he's like
oh you were that guy yeah wow so you did
have a dark time in your life
gee whiz but that one was more like just
on a whim
so you're good now yeah i'm good yeah
i was i was never too bad it was just
like
i was around a ton of bad influence yeah
just bad [ __ ]
oh wow you know what we'll get into that
another another episode
the dark history of wiggy so that'd be
like a dark comic book you know what i
mean
exactly it'll be somebody should animate
it you know and it'd be like and it was
a dark it was a dark night at the skate
park
yeah i used to well i used to live in
this [ __ ] ratchet
house in north hollywood that was why
was this why was it ratchet
it was just like never a moment where
there wasn't music
slapping um i you know i'd like
go to bed at i'd wake up at like 5 00
a.m to like
just 30 people still in the crib
it was yeah it was pretty bad but that
sounded very drugs and alcohol yeah
definitely type of thing yeah
young party like i mean i was like 18
19. so
it was when i first moved out here and i
was from seattle
yeah jesus yeah and then you just
so what got you what what what changed
for you um
well uh i don't know people
was on your throat was it your third
arrest no
no luckily i don't really have a
criminal past that's uh
but yeah that was your background
yeah that was my background but no but
um yeah i just uh
i don't know just young and dumb and
around people that were
doing crazy [ __ ] and getting a lot of
success
and also you oh you said that's the path
i guess yeah i mean it's kind of just
the cliche
story i guess yeah look at look how look
how uncomfortable he is
talking about it hearing in his voice
like this is the first this is the most
emotion he's shown since i've met him
he's like just like well you know i
don't really know what i think about it
no i'll talk about anything we can go
anywhere all right well you know we'll
save it we'll save it
hey everybody i want to talk to you
about my new sponsor i have another
sponsor it's
credit karma credit karma i actually use
credit karma
it's a way to find out your credit score
and and you get like
actually you can see all the good deals
all your credit information is in one
place it's actually very useful i use it
all the time and i've been using it for
years
and now they're a sponsor so i'm not
just you know talking out on my ass
about this credit karma is great
so who doesn't want instant
gratification if you're looking for
satisfaction there's no need to wait
with credit
karma money you could win cash
reimbursements and
debit per and for debit purchases so
credit karma they got a lot going on
right now they even got
they even have a checking account credit
karma money is a brand new checking
account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making
purchases credit karma money has already
given away over three million dollars in
instant karma to over
50 000 credit card members and
counting look right now visit
creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma
all right go to creditkarma.com win
money to sign up for free and start
winning
instant karma guys that's
creditkarma.com
when money instant karma is sponsored by
credit
karma no purchase necessary exclusion
and terms apply
c rules banking services provided by mvp
bank
member fdic maximum balance and transfer
limits
apply let's get back to the show
so i don't know what you guys think of
the episode so far so even at this point
right now like you know please give us a
like you know
if you if you like it we need to know no
dislikes take that just like away
no dislikes yeah just get those that was
another thing like what do people want
to see uh
now that i'm helping or uh like should
we try some stuff out some do some new
stuff what do uh people
want to see so leave some comments
that's exactly the thing you know do we
want
because like tick tock skits uh check
out the
eric and rachel doing some gaming skits
look at this this guy's he's even
bringing my girlfriend i love it well i
thought that would be funny you know
yeah i think so too she would love that
she always wants to be a part of stuff
so but that's
we got you here you can like film and
stuff so exactly this is great
yeah tick-tock whatever i got to get my
tick-tock my tick-tock is terrible i
don't know i don't
get anything on it we'll get it popping
for sure they'll see mine when he thinks
the pop man
how many things can you pop up and
they'll be
they'll go crazy i guarantee it
clubhouse tick tock
instagram [ __ ] club twitter um
reels even on even in here's the thing
instagram
is actually three different apps yeah
that's true okay
you have stories reels and posts yeah
it's snapchat
uh snapchat it's all of them in one tick
tock yeah
and now even on youtube you know youtube
has a sort of reels
section like a mini video section too on
youtube yeah i got stuck on that on my
i got put in that i guess somehow i
ended up there on my phone
i was like what am i on right now yeah
this is exactly what i'm talking about
like i don't even know where that
section is yeah i had no idea explore
page
how do you but how do i even make those
type of videos right
you know that's the thing i'm trying to
figure out yeah it's like go to my
channel oh here we go
oh create a short beta oh that's what
it's called
creative shorts oh that's all there's 50
it's 15 seconds
right i'm just going to do it right now
hey guys this is my first
short on instagram while i'm filming my
podcast because i'm talking about it
with my new helper
so which make sure you watch it riffy
with griffin look i'm doing a pocket
it's like it's meta right now there's
some kind of weird universe i'm doing
right now
you know gcu yeah the gc i like that the
gcu
[Laughter]
yeah that's weird though they're just i
mean every app is trying to just
capitalize on all of it and like twitter
did stories i thought that was like
the biggest fail right oh twitter one
yeah they called it called fleeks yeah
fleets like just call them stories yeah
man like it's like you know
do they have the the are they do they
have the the patent on that
right yeah stories yeah
okay first what is this call i don't
even know what this one's called first
short i'll say so they call them shorts
first
short see i put it in upload it
that's so weird yeah like insta i always
feel like
instagram i called it though i
said instagram was gonna start they
either gonna try to buy clubhouse or
they're going to do it themselves
and sure enough they got this thing
coming out where they're going to be
doing the same thing
twitter's doing it too twitter has like
a you could talk
to people thing i could see that working
more on twitter for sure you think so
i mean i could see them doing some sort
of clubhouse type
thing adding a tab where it's like
just voice voice rooms or whatever yeah
yeah have you been on clubhouse
yeah a couple times it was pretty boring
if you asked me
yeah i don't know i don't i don't my
roommate's on there or he was on there a
lot
yeah i'm one of my friends aaliyah she's
she's like the queen of clubhouse
and i just i don't get it i mean i do
get it i shouldn't say i don't get it i
do get it i just don't have the energy
like this is like you coming here and
helping me with my podcast is something
i should have done a hundred episodes
ago but i'm just so
like it's just tough you know you know i
feel like i'm stuck in my ways or
whatever so i'm trying to like
break from that so i can really expand i
mean i started gaming i did all this
stuff and it's just like
it just becomes so overwhelming because
i'm i'm so old school so i have to like
break myself of that so
here i am you know yeah i'm helping i
got the tattooed
you know ex-felon
no none of that sonic the hedgehog hair
i'm a sweet guy so see anytime you have
to say you're a sweet guy
like any time that any time that i don't
like you you think that was believable
right now
oh my god so you just so you just
see you you had this instagram with all
this attention
you know you just you always look you
always look like a tortured soul on your
instagram
like you always look like just like that
one of those white boys that's like
hold me because i am i'm oh girls i'm
hurt someone hurt me
i have like no new pictures i just have
been reposting old stuff why is that
i don't know i feel like the shape yeah
i definitely that
and uh i knew this i knew it was
something vain i knew no but it's also
like it's also just like i don't
i all those pictures that i took like
were mainly taken by this one friend of
mine
and i mean i don't know i just don't i
don't have
anybody taking pictures like of like
that of me anymore oh yes
okay so it's just like you make it sound
like you're you make it sound like
you're um
like you have ocd about your pictures
well i mean are you like are you like
that about everything about your
pictures about your art it's just i
don't think i've taken anything
where i look uh decent in a long time
vain this [ __ ] is so you just
think you're hot [ __ ] huh
no you do huh no you just you just think
you're like you're like
i'm hot do you ever say that to yourself
well no but it's a hard thing because
it's like
well it's hard because it's it's like i
would
rather post more i mean i and i kind of
do i've gotten more into it but i'd
rather post my work and be appreciated
for my work but it's hard because
nobody cares about the video stuff they
just want to see a picture of me
shirtless you know and you can you give
it to him every time well yeah
i tried it well i break it up with some
art you know i've thrown
some video you go to my page there's
some there's a little there's a decent
amount i think there's
more video stuff than there is shirtless
pics so do you feel
holed do you feel like exactly i am more
than just my
glistening hot chest unfortunately is
that how you feel about it unfortunately
yes
so you just feel like a piece of meat i
mean at times because it's just like wow
it's like what i can't like hot boy
problem nobody cares about my video
stuff
they do care what are you talking about
they care like
it's it's not one over the other it
doesn't have to be
separate you know what i mean like i i
have i'm funny you have to be funny you
know so you say
do i go are people only watching my
podcast because i'm funny right
yeah so you know you know what i mean
but they can have both
yeah and then you you do the gaming and
you know some people care about some
stuff yeah you know you're right but
it just seems uh at times it seems like
that's all they care about
oh so you don't trust people then i
don't trust
everybody no no i'm not saying you have
to trust everyone but do you have trust
issues because of that like do you
always think people are in your life
because they're trying to like
no not necessarily okay i i try to see
the best in everybody
i think do you yeah
well you know what you have a tone that
i feel i feel that you believe that yeah
but you've been let down a lot yeah
tight here and there i mean
and in industry [ __ ] too you know oh for
sure
for sure for sure it's a tough business
man yeah so
you know this is a tough business i'm
just kind of
here playing it by you doing my best
that's right that's kind of my take on
that that's all that's the moment yeah
that's all we can do
all right when i see your pictures
always think to myself damn i don't
remember the last time
i was shirtless in public we got to take
a a
uh twinning shirtless pic are you
kidding me this is not we got to
see what i look come on man i gotta work
out some more listen all right we'll
start working
out my goal is i want to be on a
honeymoon with rachel with my shirt off
and be like
yeah proud of it yeah but i don't know
when the last time i
i have to find this picture i have a
picture of myself
from like when i worked at a summer camp
when i was like 20
and looking like a real pimp yeah i had
like my shirt off and i was like because
i was the lifeguard
dude it might be 20 years since i've had
my shirt off in public
like you don't even think you know you
don't even think of it when you're just
like a chubby guy
and as you get older and you get out of
shape you don't even
think of like when is the last time you
did that so you better take advantage of
this now you better stay in shape
because you're right because you're all
talking about you're making the choice
to not have your you know put pictures
like that up
but this is going to be when the world's
going to make the choice for you
you're right so you better take care of
this while you can
that's facts are you done getting
tattoos no
i don't think so i'll probably uh yeah
i'll probably get covered
really you want to have like sleeves and
your whole chest not like
every inch but like a good
good covering i want to do i want to get
my chest soon do you think that anyone
ever regrets that
yeah probably you think that people wake
up
52 like how stupid i mean i have lisa
simpson on my neck
so i mean i'mma wake up at 52 with lisa
who's lisa simpson from the simpsons
you ha
oh i'm so sorry
i'm so very it's okay it's a meaningful
one so that is
is it meaningful yeah all right where
are we at on time
combining the two i think you can see
the time yeah 27 28 minutes 20 minutes
okay then i wonder how much we recorded
or the other one we probably need some
more yeah
probably good probably 20 more minutes
yeah good 24 minutes yeah okay well this
is good let's what else what else would
you what else did you have on the left
you talked about vaccines um
seattle oh what's what about seattle i
don't know seattle yeah you
i i saw online you won a comedy
contest in seattle what did you like
read my bio oh jesus this is one of
those terrible interviews
you know so you see that you're uh you
were on a workaholic so
tell us about that how did that come
about ugh
dude do you know the first one of the
first out-of-town gigs i did when i
started doing comedy was i went to
seattle
and i drove from ballet i just wanted to
try it
how'd you like it it was terrible i'd
never do it again it was the worst you
didn't take the coast i assume
i did take the coast but it was still a
16 hour drive i mean yeah it's
definitely
a nightmare dude i think i've taken the
coast once
and the rest of the times i just got to
do i five yeah you gotta do i find it
not worth it it's not but i mean i do
love the pacific
northwest yeah i just think there's some
beautiful places in oregon and i really
love seattle seattle is one of my
favorite cities
yeah it's a great it was a great place
to grow up for sure yeah man definitely
blessed
especially with all the like the the was
the all the
grungy alternative music scene was that
going on
in your childhood or was it like it was
the tail end of that yeah
i'm 97 so like i was just
i was kind of after that a little bit
yeah oh i was born like
yeah march 30th 1997. oh you're march
baby i'm a march baby yeah
yeah but i'm 12th so i'm pisces okay
right before aries
here uh you're oh i'm saying that like i
know
like yeah like i know that [ __ ] oh
rachel probably knows
you're an aries yeah is she into all
that
she thinks she thinks she is you know
they all think they are she thinks she
is but she's really not
you see all my stuff i have over here
like you asked about my wand yeah what
is that voldemort swan no why would it
be voldemort's one
are you just throwing names out just to
try to be like that it kind of looks
like i can't swan
dan that you can't just say oh it's like
the bone
it looks like a bone one kind of oh
that's true this uh
lady that works at the comedy club in uh
in um tennessee not tennessee nashville
is that funny bone um is it the funny
ball
i think it is there's like twenty bones
right in uh
that's not a funny bone in uh i don't
know in i was just shooting nashville
nashville something to rather i forgot
the comedy club there already i haven't
been into comedy for so long i don't
even know
all the places but yeah she gave me this
because she heard me talking about harry
potter on stage
so she gave me this wand so that's
really nice
then i have my goggles that i got from
being on the crown channel
that's dope mad max yeah it does look
very mad max yeah
i didn't really like the mad max though
you know like the new one the new one
actually i just saw it again for the
first time and i actually enjoyed it
more now than i did the first time i saw
it
it's pretty crazy yeah good production
value
oh is that what you're into and when you
watch something now you're always
looking at how it's shot you can't
i do look at that a lot yeah you can't
just enjoy it i mean i enjoy it and
check it out i love that you know when i
look at stuff like if i'm looking at a
television show or something like that
i always you know what i do is i count
shots i count setups
that's what i do when i'm watching a
show like i can't
if i'm not enjoying it if it doesn't
grab me then i start
counting setups yeah i'm sure you have a
a whole different way of watching things
but but what i mean by that for the
people that don't know what i'm seeing
counting setups is like
it's just whatever the shot so like if
you see a scene between two people and
they're standing in front of each other
that's gonna be a minimum of two setups
meaning they have to get this shot of
over this guy's shoulder onto this
person and then they do another shot of
this guy
behind that person's shoulder over to
this person so when i see that i know
that that was two setups
and then if you see like you know a wide
shot or you can see both of the
characters
in the scene that's a third setup and
sometimes you see like
a close-up of the person talking that's
actually
another setup even if it's the same
angle as another one so sometimes you
see a scene and you're like damn
there was like four or five setups in
that scene and i started thinking wow
what kind of day was that i wonder if
that took two days or three you know
and that's where my mind goes when i'm
watching movies and tvs if i'm not
completely enthralled by them so do you
do the same thing
what do you look for when you're looking
at stuff you're looking at lighting
shots
lighting shots for sure what boutique
[ __ ]
but what can you remember something that
you were looking at and you were kind of
like oh
i really admired how it was shot or did
you ever think i wonder why they did it
like that
yeah definitely um you do you have
something off the top of your head did
you you know
see yeah he's not good in the moment
you see how i got it i'm practicing you
see how i got him stomped
well there's there's a ton of shots in
mad max that one that when they go into
the storm i mean that's insane that was
well i mean a lot of that i mean it's
just so much cgi yeah on there
so much cgi is i mean it was like you
know you know
i guess that part of the movie was good
i just i tell you my biggest problem
with mad max
it was i don't like
a movie about that particular subject
being pg-13
yeah i you know if you're talking about
a post-apocalyptic
warlord who has sex slaves that he's
impregnating
that's not pg-13 so don't try to
sugarcoat it with pg-13
let's just show everything let's let it
be violent and gory
and and you know raping in pillaging
because that's what that universe is
it's a post-apocalyptic nightmare and
you're trying to water it down
maybe the pg-3 i just don't like that
yeah i can see that that's my but i'm an
adult
i want adult stuff all right i want
adult stuff
i well i rewatched the original uh mad
max after i
saw the oh that's crazy right yeah
completely not that far i mean there's a
scene where the guy rapes the girl and
then he shoots an
arrow in her [ __ ] you know what i mean
like that was
that's the 80s you know i'm not saying
we don't need to go that far
but maybe i am maybe i'm like let's just
get back to the way it was the good old
days of
like you know violence and gore yeah you
know but
i just that's what i like like did you
see mortal kombat no i haven't seen that
of course you didn't but there's this
like death scene in mortal kombat where
the guy has this iron hat you know what
i mean
and he like the iron hat flings into the
ground
and then it starts spinning and he like
beats this girl up
flings her over and you know
pushes her into this spinning thing and
it was like a
like a lumberyard chainsaw
and her body split in half and i was
like oh
my god and i was like that's what i like
so they they made they like uh
copy the video game yeah like the
finishing moves that's
him yeah but overall the movie was not
good
yeah i heard the story line wasn't
really yeah
but i'll watch it yeah looks sick yeah i
mean
but you know you want some some
entertainment i watched that you know
what another movie i watched
is that um michael b jordan movie
without remorse
the tom clancy um i didn't
i didn't hate it you know
i didn't hate it and at the same time i
didn't love it
it just it didn't pop
for me without remorse it did
not pop it was like you know
you know it was you know one of these
like good action movie james bond
superhero type guy
is you know trying to avenge his
family's death
you know that's that's like one that's
just a long time storyline in hollywood
you know yeah it's like all the movies
where it's like oh
his wife is killed and he has to get
revenge and that's you know that's what
this
movie is about but at the same time it
had like this like espionage
america's terrible government type of
storyline which i sometimes i get sick
of
i get sick of like like all the movies
that come out now where it's like
somehow the united states government has
to be terrible in the movie
and are there some people in the higher
ups who are not doing anything correct
and this
lone agent who's been killing people for
his whole career
all of a sudden has a conscience
conscience you know what i mean
like that's always the story line in
these things now the the spy
the the hired killer who now doesn't
want to kill anymore and he's changed
his name you know
and the powers that be that have been
using him and i'm just like shout out
yeah you know yeah things have gotten
cliche that's for sure
you see how excited he sounded about
that
i told you i'm monotone i promise i'm
like like are you even involved
right now this is the thing that i want
to know are you involved is this
at this point now guys put your comments
like should i should i dump them should
i get rid of them should we try someone
new already
because he is just
i'm trying wiggy tone we'll call it yeah
welcome to the gcu and this is a wiggy
tone wiggy doom
we get home
oh okay there you go you got a little
got some pipes a little bit of pipes did
you did you ever want to be a singer
no my mom was always like you can sing
so good and i'm like
oh you would have been you would have
been that kid on american idol
did you try to sing for your mom though
no not really i was never really
into singing why not i'll sing in the
shower so you sing in the [ __ ] what are
you singing in the shower
what do i sing in the shower um some
white boy rocker [ __ ]
i was saying sorry are you like or is it
like rap and you're like saying the
n-word
and [ __ ] dude oh that reminds me
there are these uh oh god there are
these kids
there's these kids these white kids that
just started posting
freestyles where they drop the n-word
and they're getting really viral
and they're just insane they're just too
too ridiculous
well what are they what are their names
they're just not hyped
no definitely don't hype them up they're
just some random kids but uh
but they're getting like love from lots
of uh
lots of black people and it just doesn't
really make sense
to me i i don't know i don't
i don't know what people are into or not
into i just try to do my thing
you know what i mean yes if you try to
understand you just you just go crazy
yeah i was wondering if you looked up
fat
white guys is that
porno i'm curious
because i'm still tripping off the
beginning of the podcast of fat white
girls yeah we got
it's immediately porno but fat white
guys does it
what does that come up
stock images see 24 000 white male stock
images
this is from saying so it's like it's so
bizarre
that when you google fat white girls
immediately
10 porn sites come up so that's all
right
we got to change that guys there's
something dirt there
but at the same time i don't know if
that's like if you're a fat white girl
and i'm putting this out there any fat
white girls watching the podcast if you
want to answer it
honestly is it like
is it like when somebody would google
that
do you want it to be like negative
stories about fat people
or do you want to be this thing where
it's like ooh
you know what i mean it's literally all
porn i don't understand
that's what i'm saying you guys get to
do it right now
but everybody did it in the beginning if
you haven't done it you came in late and
you're just thinking about right now
google right now fat white girls
all porno i don't it's amazing
and i just did it as a just this is like
it's just in my head i was just like
okay then you can like search for things
wig and you just go fat like for
instance fat white girls and then it's
like home partner point point reporter i
was like oh [ __ ]
yeah i was sure is this in my history is
i'm am i messing up
do you ever go to the inc incognito part
of the web
incognito browser when you're going to
look at like
some porno of course yeah
you have to go the private brother yeah
right got to
because you know if you don't you forget
that you have it open
because like when you look at porn
you're not there's a purpose for that
and when that purpose is done you don't
necessarily
shut everything down that's like when
you go on firefox
like you use a different browser and you
forget and then you like minimize it
yeah yeah you minimize it but then like
you might open it up and somebody's
there and you're like oh yeah let me
check this thing
and it's just like you know whatever
you're into is like on the screen and
you're just like
i don't know how this guy here what my
computer is tripping i mean history too
you gotta
that's why you go to the private browser
or the incognito because it just
immediately wipes it away
i mean obviously the person that thought
of that is because of this
it had to be right like some programmer
got caught
too many times looking at porn by his
wife
and he was like you know what i need to
be incognito
and then he said well what should i call
it and then
he's telling the other people they go
we'll just call it incognito
yeah private browsing just call it
private browser because you can't call
it porno browser
cause then your girlfriend or wife
husband whatever would be like
why you in the porno browser
right because that it couldn't be the
name of it no
i don't know it's all just as bad though
yeah
it all means the same it all means the
same thing right yeah
like what is the point like what is okay
it's like give me five like chat
everybody in chat and looking in the
comments right now
give me five things that you would use
the private browser for that's not porn
you know
yeah it's hard to come up with it's you
know what i mean because here's the
thing too like when you like you have
your bank information and everything
saved so like your passwords are just
right there
you know what i mean so you don't you
know so you're not you're not
necessarily trying to uh
you're not necessarily trying to like oh
because i want to go to my banking it's
not banking
what is it for like if you can name me
five things that's
not porn that you use private or
incognito browsers for
please i want somebody to because this
then it should just be called porno
browser
maybe like medical [ __ ] you could be
looking at
okay so there's one you don't want you
don't want people right right right
right yeah i can't think of man like you
got like a bump on your dick and you're
like you don't
you're like let me let me search bump on
my yeah exactly because you don't want
[ __ ] like
targeted ads coming up oh true they're
like you know you have a bumpy dick
use this dick bumps you know it's like
exactly yeah i hate that sometimes that
dude i talked about this last week
but a scary thing on your phone i don't
know if you went and checked
after i after i showed that but you know
when you go to
your pictures of your phone
and you go to the search area oh yeah
you remember you know and you go
down categories these categories i
didn't make these categories
the phone literally is figuring out
what's in the picture
and making a category for you yeah cats
animals cars
you see that performances that's that's
the one right
performances wow that's great yes you
probably probably have the same category
yeah sports and
orchestra lakes i have a lakes category
yeah i have tied up white boys that's
crazy
how did that one get
this is my trick i invite people over to
do my podcast and then they disappear
they're never worried about me but that
yeah but that would be dumb like
wouldn't that that would be a terrible
serial killer
yeah you'd get it people were like what
he was on your podcast where'd he go
after that
i don't know i have one uh
i have one auditoriums fireworks
basketball
cars sports performances beaches
orchestra
auditorium i have one that says
orchestra orchestra
yeah this is weird is it like actual
orchestra
one of them's the comedy store there's a
picture of a comic on stage
and the crowd is looking at it and it
says comedy story no it says orchestra
that's
weird that's hilarious oh a lot of them
are like that it's like
because it you know what and i know why
they think it's an orchestra
because it looks like it looks like that
looks like but it's not
yeah yeah it looks like you know the the
conductor standing in front of but it's
actually
so they're so they're wrong about that
one they didn't get that one right
that one actually should be stand-up
comedy yeah mine has mine has
performances and it's just like a bunch
of pictures of
artists people on stage dude
do you have like too many pictures on
your phone um i try to like keep
pretty clean i have eleven thousand
eleven
thousand is that a lot oh yeah what is
that noise i realize just a
freaking ac uh yeah i think that's a lot
like have you ever just like i can't
have you ever tried to go in your phone
and just sort of try to
figure out like i need to delete
pictures
yeah i usually try to go by like
screenshots
like i go by oh that's true by a section
and then try and
well i don't want that they save
everything like if you make a video for
instagram oh by the way i also have
another video for you to put together
because
we went rachel and i went ring shopping
oh you know
so yeah we went ring shopping and i saw
the ring that she liked so
she she listens to my podcast so i don't
want to take too many details sometimes
she doesn't sometimes she doesn't
so right now it's like i don't know
should i give false information right
now to lead her on like like a
like a false trail that's like what i'm
going to do but i have talked to the guy
you know i'm i am going to get her ring
she already knows i'm going to get a
ring so i could just say this i'm going
to get the ring guys
i'm getting the ring you know and i'm
getting a ring from the place that she
wants me to get the ring from
you know and i know like i had so many
people hit me up about like yo dude i
got a guy
i got a guy he's a diamond guy and you
go downtown
you knock on the door four times you say
what up and then like the guy lets you
in the back room it's like
adam sandler pops up yeah exactly i have
so many stories like that
about where people are telling me where
i should get the ring from but it's like
whatever
this is the ring she wants and she wants
it from this like this type of place
you know cartier tiffany's you know she
wants that experience and i'm totally
like who cares it ain't for me
you know what i mean yeah so hell yeah
yeah she was so excited that's exciting
yeah so i'll send you these videos and
she sent me some videos too
of her taking videos of us perfect
so then you have to put those together
for the patreon and that's erica fan.com
no
um we're gonna work on the website too
this guy we'll see what this guy does
right so we don't know people might love
this episode or people might be like
ugh yeah but you're like my rudy now
you're like rudy
i wish i was as good as rudy
she's so funny and doesn't even she
doesn't even try yeah yeah she doesn't
even try and she's funny so yeah so but
maybe we got to get you and rudy to do a
podcast together
maybe you guys are you know maybe i'll
have rudy on i should ask her if she
wants to do that she'll be on
that would be a good episode yeah yeah
yeah that's actually funny that's that's
absolutely hilarious actually yeah i
want to get her on rudy from bad friends
is on oh that's yeah you know what we're
good we're going to try to make that
happen you know and i think that you
know what i think we're good
wrap it i think we're wrapped up right
now a good good uh
long episode of riffing with griffin
yeah this is it so you know guys this is
nate
uh what is it wigerman wigman
is that jewish uh i might
i was just talking about this with my
dad he said that somewhere down the line
they took out
a second n on the end of my name so i
guess we were jewish somewhere down the
line
that doesn't make any sense i don't know
it's it's german but would it like to
escape
auschwitz that's why he was i think
that's what he was saying he was saying
they took off the end because they
didn't want
oh wow that was like something yeah so
you escape okay that's interesting i
don't know i don't know
i don't know i need to get a
ancestry.com i need to do that
do you want to do that i don't want to
do it you don't want i have one my
friend gave me for
christmas and i i could do but i just
don't want to do it i don't really want
to know
i want to like no i want to like i want
actual like
pictures of everybody down oh you want
it no
because you're white so you're his you
can go back and be like oh look
pieces of [ __ ] well i mean yeah i mean
they're
here here's what i know 100 percent yeah
that's inevitable
somebody in your family you know it was
a piece of [ __ ] at a certain point but
it is what it is
everybody was a piece of [ __ ] but still
you can still find a lineage of like you
know it sucks when you you look at your
history and it's like always some
you know you either being bad stuff is
being done to you
or you're doing bad stuff to other
people right so which side do you want
to be on really
you know what i mean yeah that's good
depends on how woke you are
exactly it's like on on cinco de mayo i
wasn't sure
is it racist to get tacos on single
tomorrow
we did get tacos or is it racist not to
get tacos on cinco de mayo that
is the question so but anyways guys
thanks for watching we're from griffin
and
i hope you guys enjoyed this it's a work
in progress i always say i'm trying i'm
trying to do stuff but here it
is officially he's going to edit this
episode and do whatever he's going to do
to it so we'll see
if he what it's like and then you know
we'll take feedback and we'll just keep
moving forward because it's ever
changing ever growing
and i appreciate you all
being here follow me you know
check me out gaming twitch.com twitch.tv
slash character for gaming
and you know we'll uh make it happen
once again
and i'll see you next oh wait before i
even say that
wigs thanks for being here you know yeah
he's for having me he's here
now yeah you got yourself big on the
screen
[Music]
no i do there he is guys
all right guys whiffer with griffin see
you next week
peace